yes I'm for each spring a 58 member jury
selects the car of the year this year it
shows the pooja 308 from among some 30
competitors our cart estimate Oscar it
says the 308 certainly looks like a
winner is Alf confessional not on ziga
tube everything but the name has changed
in the new Peugeot 308 gone is the
obirrhat design with a huge radiator
grille and paji appearance the grill has
shrunken the headlights are smaller but
more striking the new model
straightforwardness and modesty are
pleasing
well playstyle increases add a dash of
excitement to the body the new Cujo 308
has an elegant dynamic appearance the
implied under ride protection keeps the
rear from being boring so yet montes is
going to test whether the car fulfills
the promise of its design
yeah that's got tortilla top of his own
he likes the idea of a screen allowing
him to control everything even the
heater and air conditioner but when the
Sun shines on it from behind he can't
see anything at all ebru it done was a
shot it's kind of disappointing to have
to cover the optional glass roof losing
the spacious feeling it provided until
he is naturally Alfreda the sooner home
gopher of course that problem can be
avoided by sticking to the basic 308
with its conventional radio and air
conditioning
that's gliding come on this is a fan of
the small steering wheel which gives the
car a sporty character but travel
distance to shift gears is a bit too
long and the gear shift could be more
precise that would make the car sport
here the new version of the pugio is 140
kilograms lighter than its predecessor
it's shorter and lower to at 4.25 meters
in length it's a match for the Gulf
montes doesn't like having to set the
steering wheel so low to be able to see
the speedometer and rev counter if you
aren't exceptionally tall setting the
steering wheel higher means your view of
the instruments is no better than in the
conventional arrangement well you look
through the steering wheel to see them
disease of the instrument is definitely
specified by an al Commission on autumn
Foreman Jewish test language out on
tahoe in lee SMS ensues in the pre-show
uses the same platform as acid when c4
picasso reducing production costs
well nobody else's a car tester
considers the display again it controls
just about everything but the radios
volume everything looks orderly and tiny
with fewer levers and buttons in the car
but is it really a good idea to have a
touchscreen controlling the heater what
if it breaks down and you can't control
the temperature in the car pujo offers
five different engines for the 308 tree
gasoline powered and two Diesel's the
one we tested the 85 kilowatt diesel
features a stop-start system which comes
a standard the manufacturer says fuel
consumption is 3.8 liters per 100
kilometers the thrifty French car sells
for twenty four thousand six hundred
euros in Germany amatis has nothing in
principle against dynamic cruise control
but with this one at the car in front of
you suddenly breaks the system goes into
pause mode and tells the driver to
resume manual control matas ass then
what is the point of a dynamic cruise
control system obstinately the temple
mod aura so what is montez's overall
rating of this car of the year
he says the puzzle 308 is a good car but
there is room for improvement here and
there so wouldn't have been his pick for
car of the year missed some coffee [ __ ]
dead
you